excuse me was you saying something you
can't tell me nothing uh-uh you can't
tell me nothing uh-uh you can't tell me
nothing hip-hop is the kind of music of
entrepreneurship it's pro aspirational
xpro becoming the man as opposed to
railing against a man if you meet
anybody in hip hop's they kind of think
of themselves and talk about themselves
as an entrepreneur when I write a blog
post it's generally to try and teach an
entrepreneur how to how to do something
well the post can take you through like
how to do it it can't teach you to
internalize it and really kind of feel
like okay I am feeling exactly what been
met and the rap lyric often complements
it in that way I wrote a post called
cash flow and destiny which is about why
billing cash flow positive is important
because you can then control your own
destiny and not be completely dependent
on outsiders and it's great for me to
explain that but until I put in Connie
saying wait till I get my money right
then you can't tell me nothing right
it's a little harder to understand as
another example i wrote a post once on
why we think founders should run their
companies and why they can often perform
better than specialist e azam the great
artist Rakim kind of summarize
everything I want to say in two lines
when he said you're just a renter rapper
your rhymes are Minute Maid I'll be here
when it fade and watching flip like a
renegade